dans les grosses exploitations plus de
100 % de la masse salariale salaires et
charges et payés avec de l'argent public
alors franchement vous me pardonnerez
cette expression un peu triviale mais
elle est belle quand même est-ce que
vous connaissez beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprise qui se réveille le matin en
disant j'ai une centaine j'ai 200
salariés et mes salaires sont payés par
l'argent public
alors bonjour je reviens vers vous comme
comme je vous l'avais promis pour
éclaircir
encore un peu cette différence qui est
une différence incroyable qu'il y a
entre les petits producteurs et les gros
producteurs de bananes notamment en
martinique beaucoup de petits
producteurs sont venus vers nous c'est
pas simple pour eux parce qu'ils sont
d'une certaine façon sous pression
d'abord ils vont pas très bien
financièrement ils sont un exemple et on
a déterminé un tonnage par salarié donc
le calcul est simple on s'est dit voilà
quand on a une grosse exploitation c'est
à dire par exemple 5000 tonnes ou dix
mille tonnes mêmes qui vont jusqu'à
25000 tonnes
on a fait un ratio entre les références
historiques par exemple dix mille tonnes
et puis le nombre de salariés allant au
total qu'il y a c'est à dire ce qu'on
appelle les productifs les gens qui sont
dans les champs les gens qui qui sont
directement liés à la production de
bananes et puis ce qu'on appelle les
improductifs au sens comptable du terme
c'est à dire d'une manière générale le
personnel d'encadrement le personnel
administratif
on prend tout ça et on s'est dit voilà
quel est le rapport et le rapport en
fait indique que dans une grosse
exploitation
on arrive par an et par salarié à
produire environ 70 tonnes de bananes
dire qu'on prend la référence historique
on divise par le nombre de salariés et
on arrive à 70 tonnes par an et par
salarié et on a fait la même chose avec
les petits producteurs pour voir un
petit peu ce que ça donne quand on est
un petit producteur
sachant que le petit producteur on les
considère y compris chez madame art
entre quelques tonnes et 500 tonnes et
là on est allé voir confier il
produisait par rapport à leurs
références historiques et on est parti
sur une base qui est une base de 100
tonnes est aujourd'hui pour produire 100
tonnes de bananes et bien les petits
producteurs
bref se mettre à quatre il ya quatre
salariés ça veut dire que en gros on
peut considérer que chez les petits
producteurs aux produits 25 tonnes par
an et par salarié
toujours sous la référence historique
voyez d'un côté 25 tonnes par an et de
l'autre côté 70 tonnes par an et par
salarié
donc ça ça va nous donner une base très
importante pourquoi parce que c'est bien
sur cette base là qui est la base des
références historiques que vont être
payés les subventions et la subvention
tvp toujours la même et les 2 404 euros
la tonne donc si j'ai un salarié qui
veut produit 70 tonnes par an 4 x 7 28
donc ils touchent à peu près 28000 euros
de subventions par an et par salarié
mais dans une petite exploitation c'est
très différent puisque dans une petite
exploitation
le salarié il va il va faire 25 tonnes
par an et par salarié et la 25 tonnes
par an et par salarié
bah ça fait vingt-cinq tonnes x 480 4 x
25 cents à peu près c'est à dire dix
mille euros de subventions alors vous
voyez d'un côté il y en a avec pau seuil
égales on ait toujours un 404 euros la
tonne on est toujours sur les références
historiques mais les petits vont
bénéficier de 10000 euros et les gros
ont bénéficié d'à peu près 30 mille
euros alors qu'est ce que ça donne en
terme de salaire on s'est aussi posé la
question en termes de salaires
aujourd'hui dans une plantation le
salaire des productif c'est à peu près
dix neuf mille euros par an salaires et
charges comprises tout et puis on s'est
dit donc qu'est ce que ça donne dans une
petite plantation à une petite
plantation c'est très différent pourquoi
c'est différent parce que dans une
petite tentation comme y'a pas beaucoup
d'argent pas tout le monde n'est pas
déclarée
la famille qui travaille et qui vient
aider le petit producteur n'est pas
forcément déclaré donc on a nécessité de
se mettre à quatre pour pouvoir sortir
100 tonnes mais on ne trouve pas ces
quatre dans le beh
donc on voit que ce montant qui
finalement rapporter à la production et
au montant très faible
il crée une distorsion également sur la
possibilité la capacité des petits
producteurs à pouvoir déclarer par
exemple les membres de leur famille et
ça c'est une distorsion majeure
pourquoi parce qu'on se rend compte que
quand on a une très grande exploitation
avec 100 200 300 salariés
il y a plus que 100 % des salaires
charges sociales et salaires inclut plus
de 100 % de la masse salariale et payés
avec de l'argent public dans les grosses
exploitations plus de 100 % de la masse
salariale salaires et charges et payés
avec de l'argent public
alors franchement vous me pardonnerez
cette expression un peu triviale mais
elle est belle quand même est-ce que
vous connaissez beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprise qui se réveille le matin en
disant j'ai une centaine j'ai 200
salariés et mes salaires sont payés par
l'argent public
franchement c'est une situation de
distorsion complète distorsion des gros
producteurs par rapport aux petits trucs
mais distorsion également des de ses
producteurs là avec tous les autres
métiers
on est aujourd'hui dans des situations
où l'argent est quand même bien qui est
indien extrêmement rare et on a là une
filière qui est capté par quelques gros
planteurs et qui vont être dans une
situation de bénéfices d'argent public
qui est considérable ça n'est pas
possible de continuer dans cette
direction là nous ce que nous disons
chére d'hommes en tout premier lieu il
faut protéger les petits producteurs
pourquoi parce que les tout petits
producteurs avec le pot seuil qu'il
touche bas il n'y arrive pas des petits
producteurs
1 ils ont à peine la tête qui sort de
l'eau les gros producteurs par contre
avec des subventions considérables au
regard de la masse au regard de leur
capacité à faire des économies d'échelle
au regard du fait que c'est très gros
producteurs sont très souvent sur les
terrains les plus propices les plus
faciles à travailler alors que tout
petits producteurs sont tus sur des
terrains qui sont des terrains
différents
moins accessibles ou là
rendement que l'on n'obtient l'hectare
n'est pas du tout le même et bien là ce
sont bien deux métiers différents et
c'est là que le bât blesse pourquoi
parce que quand on commence à parler des
possibles les gros producteurs montrent
en ligne pour dire quoi pour dire ah si
vous touchez le posei vous allez tuer
les petits producteurs
sauf que les petits producteurs sont
devenus les gardiens du procès des gros
producteurs et c'est ça la réalité c'est
que le jour où les petits producteurs
n'ont plus de raison d'être
eh bien il n'y a plus de raison d'être
au niveau de cette subvention dont je
rappelle qu'elle était là pour garantir
l'emploi divisé par deux en 13 ans
garantir un revenu équitable pour les
petits producteurs
c'est loin d'être le cas quand on voit
que 40% des petits producteurs ont mis
la clé sous la porte en 13 ans et puis
permettent la dynamique de cette filière
est la seule dynamique qui a prévalu en
réalité c'est la dynamique au profit des
gros planteurs alors ensuite on s'est
posé la question de savoir mais que
représente cette filière sur le plan
économique et sur le plan économique
cette filière on nous dit s'appelle ali
d'emploi j'ai entendu ça ya pas très
longtemps dans une émission de
télévision
et ben non ça fait pas vingt mille
emplois quand on regarde de près ce que
représente la filière banane aujourd'hui
en martinique tout compris les petits
les gros est les métiers connexes et ben
ça représente environ 4000 emplois et
pas vingt mille et quand on regarde le
poids du produit intérieur brut la
richesse produite par la banane un qui
vient contribuer qui vient s'ajouter à
la richesse martiniquaise qui fait
partie de la richesse nationale est bien
la banane représente moins de 3% du
produit intérieur brut
donc moins de 3% des salariés moins de
3% du produit intérieur brut
par contre 40% du procès y les fonds
politiques y sont réservés à la totalité
des cultures pour la totalité des
territoires français d'outre-mer qui
sont éligibles
là ça représente 40 % dont on est bel et
bien dans un effet de rente
c'est une rente et cette inadmissible
alors nous ce que nous voulons nous
voulons aujourd'hui que soit rétabli une
forme d'équité que cet argent puisse
aller vers d'autres producteurs
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui
jeunes de la martinique qui veulent
s'installer mais pas simplement dans la
banane qui veulent s'installer dans tous
les métiers quand ils s'aperçoivent
qu'au fond l'argent public et prix
captée par un tout petit groupe
ça n'est pas acceptable ce en dit long
également sur les politiques publiques
aujourd'hui mais comment depuis 13 ans
nous n'avons pas fait une évaluation
très précise de ces politiques publiques
comment est ce qu'on peut lire encore
dans un rapport de l'odeadom qui est un
rapport qui nous donne la situation
réelle et c'est l'organisme payeur qui
peut constater qu' il y à une
disparition des petits producteurs
mais il faut pas faire une disparition
des petits producteurs il faut mettre en
place les éléments correctifs qui vont
permettre d'aller au delà de ça dont moi
je dis aujourd'hui il faut soutenir les
tout petits producteurs
ces petits producteurs la 0 à 500 tonnes
il faut les soutenir
c'est fondamental de les soutenir je les
invite d'ailleurs à mme à venir vers
nous à se rapprocher de nous parce que
on va prendre en compte leurs doléances
parce que on va essayer de comprendre
mieux ce que nous pouvons faire pour eux
en tout cas nous nous voulons les
protéger
parce que ils sont de véritables petits
entrepreneurs et qu'il faut les
considérer comme tel parce que ils sont
en même temps des gens qui aujourd'hui
tiennent l'écologie de la martinique a
parce qu'ils ont de petites
exploitations et que en faisant vivre de
petites exploitations sur des terrains
qui sont difficiles d'accès y contribue
fortement au maintien de l'écosystème
donc il faut les protéger et il n'ya pas
de commune mesure entre les petits
producteurs et les gros producteurs
alors on va agir aujourd'hui chez les
dogues de manière d'une manière claire
on va demander l'organisation d'une
enquête parlementaire sur cette question
là autant nous allons saisir le
parlement est la commission à bruxelles
parce que il n'est pas possible
aujourd'hui qu'un tout petit groupe
s'arroge autant d'argent public l'argent
public n'est pas là pour faire la
fortune de quelques-uns l'argent public
c'est le bien public à répartir sur
l'ensemble des acteurs économiques donc
soutien des petites entreprises et
j'apporte vraiment
on salue et mon soutien fraternel à tous
les petits producteurs et ils peuvent
véritablement compter sur nous à très
bientôt dans une vidéo n'hésitez pas à
nous rejoindre
si vous voulez de soutenir première
chose abonnez vous un autre chef laïque
et cette vidéo c'est très important fait
la circuler interpellé moi
à très bientôt